mentorship is not something you ask
somebody to do like will you be my
friend it doesn't work like that I
firmly believe that innovation is born
out of the struggle innovation is born
out of the the resourcefulness that you
are forced to figure out success is a
feeling it's not it's not a series of
checkmarks and goals
I think people define success as as
finish lines need motivation watch a top
10 I believe nation what's up it seven
my one word is believe and I believe in
you I believe you have an amazing gift
inside to you that I want to see
exploded onto the world so let's get
your motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
on today's lessons from a man who went
from growing up in London
Johannesburg Hong Kong and the United
States to becoming a best-selling author
marketing consultant and speaker
he's simon Sinek and here's my take on
his top ten rules success vol 3 enjoy
let's kick things off with rule number
one my personal favorite believe biggest
risk you've ever taken I completely
changed the course of my life and career
when I discovered this thing called the
Y I abandoned what I was doing and said
I want to do that and people thought I
was crazy they thought I went out of
business but I was so I believed in it
so much I have to caution into the wind
I think Y has been the key my whole life
to live Y so it's it's a little kid
question that we grow out of here some
reason rule number two is develop
mentorships here's what I've learned
about mentorship mentorship is not
something you ask somebody to do like
will you be my friend it doesn't work
like that when you find somebody you get
along with you share values you share
beliefs you spend time with them you get
to know them you develop trust you take
us you're vulnerable with them you open
up to them and you discover that you
become friends it's what happens you
start off as simply acquaintances in my
experience mentorship is exactly the
same there were people who were much
more experienced than me who had wisdom
that I didn't have and I'm when I would
call him they would take my calls and
when I would ask them questions they
would always take the time to give me
answers and over the course of time they
became my mentors like they became my
friends and I remember one time I was
with one of my mentors Ron brooder an
amazing guy and I was leaving his house
and I put my arm around him I said you
know I'm glad you're my mentor and he
looked at me and he said I'm glad you're
mine and it caught me completely
off-guard and true mentorship like true
friendship is not a one-way street it's
not about one person only giving advice
the other both people are showing up to
give and both people are showing up to
learn but you kind of ask someone to be
your mentor especially someone who's a
total stranger knock on their door and
say will you be my mentor if they don't
know you you've never met them it's like
friendship you cultivate a relationship
and if that person is always there for
you and wants to see you thrive and
succeed and believes in you then perhaps
they will become your mentor like making
a friend rule number three
put your why into action discovering
your Y is just the beginning in order to
enjoy all the benefits of having a
clearly articulated Y you'll need to
have the courage and discipline to use
it like Thomas Edison said vision with
that execution is hallucination there is
an ideal order for implementing your Y
though sometimes reality does get in the
way and it all starts with you our
natural tendency is to start with the
tangible we define our value by what we
do so it takes practice to start with Y
like riding a bicycle at first we're
unsure unsteady we're in our heads
thinking about all the things we need to
do pedal fast keep enough speed so we
don't fall over we have to really
concentrate we may even fall over you
can scrape our knees but we get back on
the bike and try again and eventually it
becomes natural starting with Y is no
different at first it feels awkward it
may not even work but with practice it
will become so natural that you won't
even be able to imagine a time when you
couldn't do it just like riding a
bicycle in time your Y will act as a
filter for many of the decisions and
choices you make it becomes a tool to
help you find a job or seize an
opportunity in which you're more likely
to succeed it removes a lot of the
guessing here's a metaphor to show you
what I mean it's called the celery test
we're constantly asking people for their
advice on what to do or how to do it
it's like going to a dinner party and
somebody says do you know what you need
you need M&Ms we've done so well with
M&Ms you've got to use M&Ms somebody
else says to us rice milk in this
economy you have to use rice milk
someone else says to us Kit Kats you
have to use Kit Kats and somebody else
says to you it's all about celery we go
to the supermarket with all this good
advice from all these smart people with
brilliant case studies and we buy
everything we've I'd kick cats and M&Ms
celery and rice milk there's a lot of
time we spend at the supermarket and a
lot of money we spend at the supermarket
and when we get to the checkout line
we're standing there with all these
products in our hands and no one can see
what we believe because we bought
everything but let's imagine we know our
why
let's imagine our wise to always be
healthy and only do things that protect
the health of our bodies
now which products do we buy given all
the same advice from all the same smart
people this time we only buy celery and
we only buy rice milk they're the only
two that makes sense we spend less time
and less money at the supermarket and
when we're standing there in line with
only celery and only rice milk now
people can see what we believe somebody
walking past can say hey I can see that
you're healthy so am I
you just attracted an opportunity or a
referral or a friend simply by saying
and doing the things that you believe
and the best part is it's scalable as
soon as I said the y-you knew exactly
which products we were going to buy this
means the more you can articulate your
why the more others will know what you
stand for and will be able to help you
make the right decisions from now on you
will work to ensure everything you do is
a good fit if you do too many things
that aren't a good fit
you'll feel uncomfortable and people
will feel that you're being inauthentic
on the other hand when you start with
why your ability to stand out find
support and work to all your natural
strengths will flourish with practice
you will learn to trust your Y you will
eventually start to see your job and the
things you do as ways to breathe life
into your cause and the better you get
at it the more you will feel that your
life and everything you do has purpose
the best way to implement your Y is to
work at it slowly you don't have to do
all the tips we suggest what is
important is that you pick up 2/3 and
commit to practicing and using them now
rule number 4
be courageous what good leaders have in
common they have the courage to do the
right thing they're people of high
character and high integrity but for me
the big one is courage it's it's very
hard to be a leader it's hard to speak
truth to power very often you might be
the one that gets in trouble or lose
your job it's hard to do the right thing
it's much easier to do the expedient
thing and
and it's also a huge undertaking to be a
leader every every moment of every day
it's kind of like being a parent rule
number five interpret nervousness as
excitement I was watching the Olympics
this last summer olympics and I was
amazed at how bad the questions were
that the reporters would ask all the
athletes and almost always they asked
the same question whether they were
about to compete or after they competed
were you nervous right and to a tee all
the athletes went no right and what I
realized is it's not that they're not
nervous it's their interpretation of
what's happening in their bodies I mean
what it what happens when you're nervous
right your heart rate starts to go your
you know you sort of get a little tense
you get a little sweaty
right you have expectation of what's
coming and we interpreted that is I'm
nervous
now what's the interpretation of excited
your heart rate starts to go you become
you're anticipating what's coming right
you get a little sort of like tense it's
all the same thing it's the same stimuli
except these athletes these these
Olympic quality athletes have learned to
interpret the stimuli that the rest of
us would say is nervous as excited they
also the same thing no I'm not nervous
I'm excited and so I've actually
practiced it just to tell myself when I
start to get nervous that this is
excitement you know and so where when
you used to feet speak in front of a
large audience and somebody'd say how do
you feel you say a little nervous now
when somebody says how do you feel I'm
like really excited actually and it it
came from just sort of telling myself no
no this is excitement and it becomes a
little bit automatic later on but it's
kind of a remarkable thing to deal with
pressure by interpreting what your body
is experiencing as excitement rather
than nerves and it's really kind of
effective it makes you want to rush for
is rather than pull back and yet it's
the same experience rule number six have
grand visions vision here's the here's
the thing that's always boggled my mind
right why is it unbalanced unbalanced
not always but unbalanced why is it that
small companies tend to be more
innovative than big companies right
small companies that are under-resourced
you can't necessarily get the best and
brightest they're gonna go to business
any day
and yet there's they come with brilliant
ideas and big companies full of
resources full of amazing people by the
little companies that come up with the
good ideas that's usually how big
companies innovate they buy the smaller
ones right why is that why is it that
the most resource companies tend not and
I think it's a question of reality and
what I mean by that is small companies
their vision is is more distant than
their grasp right they have delusions of
grandeur we're gonna change the world
change industries reinvent this reinvent
that we have no money and no people but
so what my point is is the grasp is
shorter than the vision and I think what
happens is as companies get bigger and
bigger and bigger with more and more
resources what they start to do is one
of two things either their grip their
vision to become well within their grasp
and they don't Riaan or they actually
bring the vision back to put within
their grasp s' right make things very
achievable difficult but achievable for
vision to truly be vision it should feel
unachievable when a small business gets
together and says here's our vision
everybody goes like this
how're we gonna do that in big
businesses really see you as a vision
maybe goes alright ya got it we'll do a
back plan and I I firmly believe that
innovation is born out of the struggle
innovation is born out of the the
resourcefulness that you are forced to
figure out because literally the vision
is way beyond your grasp
regardless have many resources you have
it should always feel overwhelming and
impossible take a group of people with
tons of resources to give them a vision
they're gonna go okay rule number seven
is serve others so how do you define
success
I think successes is is seeing those
around you work to their natural best
and creating a momentum for a vision
towards a vision that will last beyond
yourself so a guy is driving a bus for
20 years got to retire he's on
Madison Avenue in New York packed
everyday as people getting on that bus
and getting off mm-hmm yes two kids wife
lives in Queens hmm he might call
himself successful another guy might be
vice president of that company who call
self unsuccessful so his success what
you make of it so it's so this success
is defined its successes of feeling it's
not it's not a series of checkmarks and
goals
I think people define success as finish
lines you know they well I ran a
marathon I'm successful the question is
a why did you run the marathon and what
happens after you've completed the
marathon do you just keep running
marathons what happens if you break your
leg and you can no longer run marathons
you know we said a lot of people set
financial goals I'm successful when I
make my first million okay now I have to
make my second million its success as a
feeling and and it's the feeling of
contribution so you were bus driver in
Queens if he has decided that his job as
a bus driver is to ensure that everyone
who gets on his bus feels better about
themselves because they got on his bus
and not another bus and so he greets
them with a smile he says good morning
he says goodbye that people remember
that that that that ride that they took
with him versus the this vice president
of the company who's made it about
himself and his financial goals
he's the one who's unhappy as opposed to
seeing those around him succeed and
those around him go home with a love of
their their day you know because they
come to work in his company every day so
I still believe success and and good
leadership are about service to others
rule number eight learn to communicate
your why what you'll find is that that
the better you are at communicating your
why people will want to work for you
regardless of the opportunity that you
afford them like they want to be a part
of it yeah we do a little thing which
we've been doing for years and years and
years called a give and take whenever
there's any kind of relationship whether
it's a an outside partnership or even
somebody who joins our team we do
something called a give-and-take where
we want somebody to be selfish and
selfless within the relationship so not
give and get but give and take so we'll
ask them what is it that you have to
give to us
you have that you you think that we need
right and they'll tell us and then we'll
say great what is it that you selfishly
want from us and we want them to tell us
what they can get from us and that's so
many when those when those things match
you have a balanced relationship because
what so example I've had it with people
will you know they'll tell me what they
what they have to offer and that's
awesome because that's what I want and
then they'll say what they have what
they want to take and they go oh I want
to work with the smart people I'm like
plenty of smart people what is it you
want to take from me they're like I want
to help build something wonderful do
that anywhere what do you want to take
selfishly from me that you can get
nowhere else and if they kind of answer
the question I won't engage in a
relationship and the reason is because
in time the relationship is unbalanced
they're gonna be giving but they're not
taking and I don't even know how to give
them what they want then they'll
complain that I'm making enough money or
that it's because it's not balanced
that's right rule number nine play the
infinite game the game of business is an
infinite game right it Bay's all the
rules there are known and unknown
players you don't know all the
competitors necessarily even in one
industry to another the rules are
changeable we haven't all agreed what
the rules are and there is no winning
the game of business right the game just
perpetuates in fact the game of business
has existed longer than every single
company on the planet today and it will
outlast every single coming up company
on the planet today if you look at the
Dow index of 30 something odd companies
that make up the down index something
like 70 or 80% of those companies are 35
years or younger right so it gets me
thinking if you listen to the language
that companies use they don't know what
game they're in they talk about being
number one talk about beating their
competition based on what agreed upon
criteria based on what agreed-upon
timeframe is that market share is a
profits is it revenues square footage
number of employees over what one month
five months six months a year five years
ten years the life of the company I
haven't agreed to those rules and so
companies can arbitrarily declare
themselves number one and anything they
want if they set the standards and the
timeframes and the only reason we do
these things on annualized basis we tend
you we tend to compare ourselves to
other organization
annually is only because we pay taxes
annually if we pay taxes every 18 months
that would be sort of the standard but
again we still haven't agreed what the
metrics are to be number one that means
the companies that are playing the
infinite game are playing against most
of the others were playing the finite
game means those finite companies find
themselves in quagmire
almost every single bankruptcy not
almost everything every single
bankruptcy is a company that's run out
of the will or the resources to play
they drop out of the game the game will
persist another company will fill their
space it's not like it's not like the
business stops of the industry ends and
the companies that are playing the
infinite game will frustrate those
finite players which I absolutely adore
so I spoke at an education summit for
Microsoft I also spoke in an education
summit for Apple now I would say about
70 to 80 percent of the executives at
Microsoft spent about 70 to 80 percent
of their powerpoints talking about how
to beat Apple at the Apple Summit a
hundred percent of the executives spent
a hundred percent of their presentations
talking about how to help teachers teach
and how to help students learn one was
obsessed with their journey with their
vision with their cause the other one
was obsessed with their competition
guess who's stuck in quagmire
guess who's frustrated by their
competition rule number ten the last one
before the bonuses tell great stories so
I'll tell you another story it's a
personal story it's not one that I share
very often and it profoundly changed the
course of my life in August of 2011 I
had the opportunity to visit Afghanistan
with the United States Air Force I had
done some work with the mobility forces
these the people that fly the tankers
and the cargo planes and Air Force One
all the big planes and the general said
to me Simon you've gotten to know us
quite well it would mean a lot to me if
you would go to either Iraq or
Afghanistan to see our
women perform their mission would you be
willing to go so I said yes they picked
Afghanistan now I didn't tell my parents
where I was going because I didn't want
them to worry I told them I was going
away with the airforce true I told them
I was going to be out of touch for a
while because I was gonna be on a lot of
planes true I told them I was going to
Germany true I just didn't tell them
from Germany I was going to Afghanistan
and I had no responsibilities I was
simply going as an observer I had two
officers who were assigned to be my
escorts and we met basically for the
first time at Penn Station in
Philadelphia where we drove to Dover Air
Force Base where we would leave for
Germany we took a big c5 cargo plane in
Germany we changed planes and we got on
a kc-135 tanker built in 1956 I was on a
plane built in 1956 where we flew to
Bagram we landed in the middle of the
night we touched down and the big door
in the side of the plane had opened but
we hadn't gotten off the plane yet we'd
been on the we'd been on the ground for
maybe 10 minutes and the base came under
rocket attack three rockets hit a
hundred yards off our nose this is how
my trip began now if you've ever been in
a war zone for those of you in the room
who have ever been in a war zone you
have you know this you have all the
feelings you're supposed to have you
just don't have them at the right times
weirdly I was incredibly relaxed and
maybe that's because the people I was
with were incredibly relaxed and I felt
safe we revenge the panic came later
we're eventually given the all-clear and
we went to our housing now the purpose
of being in Afghanistan we were gonna be
in the country for up to 30 hours and
the goal was to witness an airdrop
mission they're not regularly scheduled
so we had to find out if there was one
as soon as we got there and it turns out
there was one first thing in the morning
so we got about two and a half hours
three hours of sleep and we went and
gone on this airdrop mission which was
incredible we sat in the back of a c-17
we flew about an hour and a half
two hours out to the middle of nowhere
Afghanistan the plane dropped down to
about two thousand feet the back door
opened and we sat there and watched as
cargo flew at the back so we could
resupply an army Forward Operating Base
it was an amazing amazing experience we
then flew back to Bagram and the goal
was to come back home
there's no regularly scheduled flight so
we have to sort of find out what flights
we can get on it's always up to the
discretion of the pilots we found a
flight that was leaving shortly after we
got back and so we asked the pilots and
they said absolutely we can join their
flight and we waited and waited and
waited and waited in a way they didn't
wait it and eventually we got on the
plane we were all strapped in literally
five minutes from leaving and the pilot
walked up to us and said I'm sorry we
need to bump you guys we need to make
more room for stretchers it was carrying
wounded warriors out of out of theatres
and they needed our space if there's
ever a good reason to get bumped off a
plane this was it so we got off the
plane and we went to look for another
flight and that's when we found out
there were no other flights until
Tuesday and this was only Saturday I was
gonna get stuck in Afghanistan for at
least four days maybe longer because we
don't know what we're gonna get on on
Tuesday and I have no way of telling my
parents they're not gonna hear from me
on the date that I told them that I
would get home immediately every fiber
of my being sank and I remember becoming
completely panicked and completely
preoccupied with one thing my happiness
my safety and my comfort and I didn't
care who had to go out of their way to
get me what I wanted I remember there
was a public affairs officer who said I
can get you to Kyrgyzstan but you don't
have the right visa and I looked at him
and I said you get me on that plane I
don't talk to people like that and I
could see myself becoming this person
that I hated some of us in the room have
worked for somebody in our careers who
wants the next promotion and they don't
care that they have to tie our turn our
lives upside down so they can get what
they want I was becoming that person we
went back to our housing and I lay down
on the bed and closed my eyes my mind
was racing I was convinced that there
would be another rocket attack on the
base I was convinced
that I was gonna get hit I was convinced
that my parents were gonna find out that
I was in Afghanistan when an arm an Air
Force officer knocks on the door I was
convinced paranoia fear everything that
you can imagine swept over me one of the
officers that I was traveling with said
I'm gonna see if I can get us on another
flight and he left the room the other
officer thinking I was asleep just
because my eyes were closed said well
I'm gonna go to the gym then and he
walked out and turned off the lights for
me I couldn't sleep
my mind was racing all I wanted to do
was get out of there I regretted saying
yes I regretted being there I didn't
want to be there I'm in the purpose
business I write and talk about this
sense of Y and sense of purpose in our
lives so I started to remind myself
Simon you need a purpose you don't have
a purpose you need a purpose I started
inventing one you're here to tell their
story
it worked for like a few minutes and
then it would slide back into my fear
and panic again and I realized what was
happening to me is I was living the
equivalent of an unfulfilled life
compressed into 24 hours I had an
amazing day I got to see something that
most people will never get to see in
their entire lives
except I didn't want to wake up and do
it again the next day and I think many
of us do the same thing we can we
confuse moments of happiness with joy
and fulfillment we confuse winning a
piece of business getting a promotion
getting an award getting recognition
doing well on a test with actual deep
fulfillment those experiences are
wonderful but happiness is fleeting
there's not a single person in this room
absolutely zero who's walking around
with an amazing sense of accomplishment
for that test that you aced a year ago
that feeling is gone fulfillment is
something entirely different it's
something you carry with you on a daily
basis whether you're enjoying the day or
not it's like loving your family you may
not like your family every day but you
love your family every day one is
fleeting the other is lasting and this
is what was happening to me I'd realize
that I
had this amazing day and I was confusing
happiness and fulfillment and so I gave
up I lay in that bed paranoid scared and
depressed and I literally gave up I
decided that if I was gonna get stuck
here I might as well make myself useful
and so I decided I was gonna volunteer I
would speak anywhere they wanted me to
speak I would carry boxes and sweep
floors all I wanted to do was serve some
of those amazing people that I'd met on
this trip I wanted to serve those who
served others and instantly this
incredible calm came over me I was even
excited this is what fulfillment means
it's not the fleeting Joy's that we may
experience it's not the accomplishments
that we achieve it's the opportunity to
serve those who serve others and upon
making this realization I had nothing
but joy and calm and excitement and
peace it was like a movie the timing was
uncanny upon making this amazing
realization the door flung open and it
was Major Throckmorton he said I got us
on a flight that's been a flight that's
been redirected but we have to go now we
have to go now we don't leave now
they're gonna leave without us where's
Matt
I said he's at the gym so he ran to the
gym we got him off the treadmill we ran
back no time to shower he put his
uniform back on we grabbed all our stuff
and we ran out to the flight line when
we got out to the flight line we could
see the plane we were gonna go we were
gonna take home see big c-17 it was
sitting right out there on the tarmac
and as soon as we got there a security
cordon came down they wouldn't let us
out to the plane because somewhere else
on base they were having a fallen
soldier ceremony and out of respect when
they have the fallen soldiers ceremony
everything stops oh and so say we we sat
on the curb and waited and I told the
guys what I had gone through in the bed
just moments ago and I cried like a baby
and this is one of the things a lot of
people don't realize about the military
crying is just fine those guys kept me
safe not just physically they made me
feel safe
and I felt totally comfortable telling
them what I was going through and how I
felt
eventually the security cordon came up
and they led us out to the plane we
would be the only three passengers
aboard this plane other than the crew
what I didn't tell you is the reason the
flight was redirected is because we
would be carrying home the fallen
soldier for whom they just had the
ceremony the army brought the flag
draped casket a bun on board all the Air
Force crew stood in a line at perfect
attention I'm a civilian I put my hand
on my heart I felt kind of stupid so I
stood at attention with the Air Force
crew as the army laid the casket in the
middle of the aircraft they all did a
very slow eight-count salute they
marched off the plane and we watched
them hugging and crying as they walked
away the crew got to work strapping this
precious cargo down we then had a nine
and a half hour overnight flight back to
Germany where I slept right next to this
casket on every other plane I went on we
talked we joked barely a word was spoken
in nearly 10 hours on every other flight
I visited the cockpit and hung out with
the crew I didn't visit the cockpit once
and I will tell you it was one of the
greatest honors of my life having just
gone through this incredibly strange
experience on the ground I had the honor
of bringing home somebody who
understands service much deeper than I
will ever understand it serve those who
serve others and you will live a life of
joy and fulfillment
now I've got some special assignments I
like bonus clips for you but before
getting to that my question of the day
is I'm curious around this idea of
changing your nervousness into
excitement have you tried that are you
going to try that what do you think of
that strategy to help relieve your
nerves and say I'm excited I'm not
nervous
let me know leave in the comments below
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever you're
one where it is
much love I'll see you soon and enjoy
the bonus clips
I'll tell you a true story a few months
ago I stayed at the Four Seasons in Las
Vegas it is a wonderful hotel and the
reason it's a wonderful hotel is not
because of the fancy beds any hotel
can go and buy a fancy bed the reason
it's a wonderful hotel is because of the
people who work there
if you walk past somebody at the Four
Seasons than this and they say hello to
you you get the feeling that they
actually wanted to say hello to you it's
not that somebody told them that you
have to say hello to all the customers
say hello to all the guests right you
actually feel that they care now in
their Lobby they have a coffee stand and
I one afternoon I went to buy a cup of
coffee and there was a barista by the
name of Noah who was serving me Noah was
fantastic he was friendly and fun and he
was engaging with me and I had so much
fun buying a cup of coffee I actually
think I gave 100 percent tip right he
was wonderful so as is my nature I asked
Noah do you like your job and without
skipping a beat Noah says I love my job
and so I followed up I said what is it
that the four seasons is doing that
would make you say to me I love my job
and without skipping a beat Noah said
throughout the day managers will walk
past me and ask me how I'm doing if
there's anything that I need to do my
job better
he said not just my manager any manager
and then he said something magical he
says I also work at Caesars Palace and
Caesars at Caesar's Palace the managers
are trying to make sure we're doing
everything right they catch us when we
do things wrong he says when I go to
work there I like to keep my head under
the radar and just get through the day
so I can get my paycheck he says here at
the Four Seasons I feel I can be myself
same person entirely a different
experience from the from the customer
who will engage with Noah so we in
leadership are always criticizing the
people we're always saying we've got to
get the right people on the bus I've got
to fill my ear on my team I got I got
the right people but the reality is it's
not the people it
the leadership if we create the right
environment we will get people like Noah
at the Four Seasons if we create the
wrong environment we will get people
like Noah at Caesar's Palace it's not
the people and yet we're so quick to
hire and fire you can't hire and fire
your children if there's if your kids
are struggling we don't say you got to
see a school you're up for adoption
so why is it that when somebody has
performance problems at work why is it
that our instinct is to say you're out
we do not practice empathy what is
empathy look like here's the lack of
empathy this is normal in our business
world you walk into someone's office
someone walks into our office and says
your numbers have been down for the
third quarter in a row you have to pick
up your numbers otherwise I can't
guarantee what the future will look like
how inspired you think that person is to
come to work the next day here's what
empathy looks like you walk into
someone's office someone walks into your
office and says your numbers are down
for the third quarter in a row are you
okay
I'm worried about you what's going on we
all have performance issues maybe
someone's kid is sick maybe they having
problems in their marriage maybe one of
their parents is dying we don't know
what's going on in their lives and of
course it will affect performance at
work empathy is being concerned about
the human being not just their output
and we have to practice empathy
[Music]
the most important work ever if you had
to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
that would be like a little beacon pay
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey
will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a
very special secret video for you check
the description for details
[Music]